All of that stuff could be like a couple stickers on my forehead and a chip in my wrist. Like, let's go. Come on. I'm so tired. Like, we're going to, by the time we're 60, we're going to look back at the days when you would leave the house and you'd have to bring all this stuff, these headphones and all this stuff. And it's just going to be, like, it's going to be in us or stickers on our foreheads. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 122, recorded on March 21st, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we chat about ChatGPT, the NVIDIA GTC Conference, and intelligence augmentation. We're back. We are back. Are we hopping straight into things?
所有这些东西都可以变成我额头上的几个贴纸和手腕里的一个芯片。走吧。得了吧。我太累了。我们到60岁的时候，回想起以前出门必须带上所有这些东西——耳机和各种杂七杂八的东西的日子，就会觉得，这些东西以后都会植入我们体内，或者变成贴纸贴在我们的额头上。欢迎收听 ADSP The Podcast 第 122 期，录制于 2023 年 3 月 21 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起聊天，探讨了 ChatGPT、英伟达 GTC 大会以及智能增强。我们回来啦。我们又回来啦。我们要直接切入正题吗？
I mean, I got a thing. If you got a thing, we can do your thing. I don't really have any things, but I'll just start off by saying it has been... What do you mean you don't have a thing? I mean, I got tons of stuff, obviously. Some nerve you have. I just meant to to say you said you had a topic to talk about so i did not mentally prepare anything that being said we recorded with zach back on february 16th ages ago yeah that was five episodes the most we've split up a single recording i i got to tell you, I love Zach. Honestly, I was thinking that, I mean, usually we do our Christmas holiday special episode where we just chat. And it's usually just you and me. I feel like Zach would fit in great. Even though it's like, you know, the annual tradition is it's just you and me.
我的意思是，我有个话题。如果你也有，那我们可以先聊你的。我其实没什么想聊的，不过我先开个头吧，最近一直……你什么意思，怎么就没话题了？我的意思是，我有一大堆事要说，当然啦。你还真好意思。我只是想说，你之前说你有话题要聊，所以我根本就没在精神上做任何准备。话虽如此，我们在 2 月 16 日和扎克（Zach）一起录过一期，那是好久以前的事了。对，那是五集以前的事了，这是我们为单次录音拆分最多的一次。我得告诉你，我超喜欢扎克的。说实话，我在想，通常我们都会做圣诞假期特别节目，就是我们两个随便聊聊。通常也就只有你和我。我觉得扎克如果加入进来会非常合适。尽管你知道，我们的年度传统就是只有你和我。
But Zach was just fantastic. I love how hard of a time he gives you. Yeah. From a place of love. But he just had so many zingers. And I just, the cold opens of those. You should just go listen to the first 30 seconds of each of the last five episodes. Because I think at least three or four of the five are him like ripping into you about the, what
但扎克表现得实在太棒了。我喜欢他总是故意给你出难题的样子。是的。那是出于爱。但他抛出的金句实在是太多了。还有那些节目的开场白。你真该去听听过去五集里每一集的头 30 秒。因为我觉得其中至少有四五集，他都在疯狂吐槽你关于那个什么……
are they, the authority filling curve and, you know, Bryce's fancy. We know. Anyways, it was, I, it brings me a lot of joy to have, have someone like Zach, you know, try and bring you down to earth, which of course he failed. He magnificently failed in doing that. But I mean, it's pretty, it's pretty hard to bring me down. It is amusing at least. I'm pretty much helium.
是什么来着，权威填充曲线（authority filling curve），还有布莱斯那些花里胡哨的……我们懂的。总之，能有像扎克这样的人来试着让你认清现实，这让我感到非常高兴，当然他失败了。他在这一点上彻底地失败了。不过话说回来，想让我认清现实可真够难的。至少挺搞笑的。我简直就是个气球。
I just rise up. But yeah, we recorded that on February 16th. And then the last time we recorded before that was February 1st. So today is March 21st, which means that we actually, mano a mano, haven't chat in over a month and a half which is probably pushing it in terms of I mean I guess we've had multiple I've been like off in the wilderness you know like I've
我只会往上飘。不过话说回来，我们是 2 月 16 日录的那期。在那之前我们录音是 2 月 1 日。所以今天是 3 月 21 日，这意味着我们两个面对面其实已经有一个半月没聊天了，如果考虑到……我的意思是，我大概有好几次都在荒野里漂泊，你知道的，就像我……
been not the literal wilderness although I do that sometimes too but I've just been off in the off exploring some things and and messing around with some new uh some new projects and so we haven't really we haven't even talked really at work yeah no we haven't uh we haven't really
我指的不是字面意义上的荒野，虽然有时候我也会那样，但我就只是去别的地方探索了一番，顺便捣鼓了一些新的……一些新项目，所以我们甚至都没怎么交流过。对，没错，我们甚至都没……
caught up i mean the most we did was although it's funny the person who i've talked with the most at nvidia the past few weeks has actually been your boss. Is it Michael? Yeah. Yeah, that's true. I guess I did see that email thread about sort of the index. Well, that's like public stuff that's going to end up in a public API, right? Well, I mean, it's...
叙过旧。我们顶多也就是……不过挺搞笑的，过去几周在英伟达里和我交流最多的人其实是你的老板。是迈克尔（Michael）吗？对。对，没错。我猜我确实看过那封关于索引之类的邮件串。好吧，那都是些最终会进入公共 API 的公开内容，对吧？好吧，我的意思是……
Or is that your topic for today? I wrote a bunch of code and I just put it on GitHub and that's what we're going to talk about today, so... Okay, okay. Well, before we hop into that, is there any update i mean we've been chatting so i mean i think the listener knows this by now if you're a regular listener bryce and i are definitely going to be in europe together in june we've got a road trip i guess we you probably haven't booked that car but we've got a road trip from like roughly the 18th i may have reserved the car have you but yeah i mean it's i
还是说这就是你今天的主题？我写了一堆代码，然后直接放到了 GitHub 上，这就是我们今天要聊的内容，所以……好吧，好吧。那在我们切入正题之前，有没有什么最新动态？我的意思是，我们一直在聊天，所以我觉得听众们现在也知道了，如果你是老听众的话，布莱斯和我都确定会在 6 月份一起去欧洲。我们要来一次公路旅行，我想你大概还没订那辆车吧，不过我们有一趟大概从 18 号左右开始的……我可能已经把车预约好了。你预约了吗？但对，我的意思是，我……
you know we we have the flights figured out. I think the only thing now is we just got to figure out the hotels and then what we're going to do. Yeah, so we'll be doing a little road trip. And because of my other third podcast, which I actually did announce on this podcast back in January, it has launched my running podcast. It's called Run for the Fun of It.
你知道的，我们已经把机票订好了。现在唯一要确定的就是酒店，还有我们要去哪里玩。对，所以我们会去进行一次小型的公路旅行。因为我的第三个播客——其实我已经在 1 月份的这档播客里宣布过了——我的跑步播客已经上线了。它叫《Run for the Fun of It》（为了乐趣而跑）。
The name came from ChatGPT, of course, because whenever it comes to creative things, I think that's actually what ChatGPT is best at. I use ChatGPT to write a heartfelt message to my girlfriend yesterday. But then I had so much fun doing it that afterwards I told her, because she was traveling yesterday and she was having a rough time I had so much fun doing it that afterwards I told her, Oh, did you get them?
这个名字当然是 ChatGPT 想的，因为每当涉及到创意方面的事情，我觉得这正是 ChatGPT 最擅长的。我昨天还用 ChatGPT 给我的女朋友写了一条深情的讯息。但我当时玩得太开心了，以至于后来我告诉她，因为她昨天在出差，而且过得不太顺心……我当时玩得太开心了，以至于后来我告诉她：“哦，你收到了吗？”
Because she, she was traveling yesterday and she was having a rough time because she, she forgot her credit cards at home. And so she was really stressed. And so I, I had a, I had DoorDash delivered to her from a restaurant that I knew she liked near where she's staying for work. And I had like a little message sent there, but it was like 120 character limit.
因为她昨天在出差，而且过得很不顺心，因为她把信用卡忘在家里了。所以她压力非常大。于是我让 DoorDash 给她送了一份外卖，是一家我知道她很喜欢的、在她出差住处附近的餐馆。我还让人带了一段简短的留言过去，但那上面有大约 120 个字符的限制。
And I'm like, you know, I could just come up with something on my own or I could use artificial intelligence. There's literally I'll have to find the Instagram reel, but there's an Instagram reel of a comedian talking about writing a poem for this girl he liked, and he used ChatGPT to do it. And then he admitted afterwards that he had used ChatGPT to do it, and then she was offended. And so then she, whatever, they left part of ways after their date. And then the next day, he sent a heartfelt message apologizing. And then, you know, they ended up dating. And the punchline of the joke is that he got chat GPT to write that heartfelt message, which like, I mean, it's like the thought that counts, right? Ramona wasn't amused, but she's never really amused by me. It's the thought that counts. I think if you're taking the time to get a, I wouldn't call
我想，你知道的，我可以自己随便想点什么，或者我也可以使用人工智能。真的，我得去找找那个 Instagram 短视频，里面有个喜剧演员在谈论为他喜欢的女孩写诗，他就是用 ChatGPT 写的。然后他事后承认自己是用 ChatGPT 写的，结果那女孩被冒犯了。然后他们就……不管怎样，他们在约会后分道扬镳了。第二天，他发了一条深情的道歉信息。然后，你知道的，他们最后还是在一起了。那个笑话的包袱就是，他让 ChatGPT 写了那条深情的讯息，这就好比……这就是“礼轻情意重”吧？雷蒙娜（Romona）并没有觉得好笑，不过她从来没真正觉得我的笑话好笑过。这就是心意嘛。我觉得如果你花时间去弄一个——我不会称之为复杂的……
it sophisticated, but like sophisticated enough AI to assist you with the, you know, creative writing that you may not be the best at, that's totally okay in my books. Well, but the funny thing is I must've spent 40 minutes working with chat GPT to write the message. That's part of the process. Just because like i was having fun with yep prompt engineering and so it probably took longer than it would have for me to write something on my own and like i'm i'm actually a pretty good communicator so i think it probably would have been better too i don't know about that but i was just like i'm a man on a mission i feel like this is the hot thing. I'm going to use it.
但算是足够复杂的 AI 来协助你进行那些你可能不太擅长的创意写作，这在我看来完全没问题。好吧，但有趣的是，我肯定花了 40 分钟和 ChatGPT 一起写那条讯息。这也是过程的一部分嘛。因为我当时玩得很开心，不断进行提示词工程，所以这花的时间可能比我自己写还要长。而且我其实是个挺擅长沟通的人，所以我觉得自己写出来的效果可能还会更好。这个我就不确定了。但我当时的状态就像是“背负使命的人”，我觉得这很火，我一定要用它。
I feel like it's kind of like how when, was it Deep Blue beat Kasparov? And then they were like, oh, no, you know, computers are better at chess. But then immediately after that, they had a contest where you could have computer-assisted humans. Yeah, computer-assisted humans. And that was like the best combination. So a human with a computer was still better. Yeah. Computer assisted humans. And that was like the best combination. Like, so a human with a computer was still better. Yeah. So, so, so actually during our, our GTC connect with the expert session, um, typically when we do these connectors, the expert sessions at GTC and, and the C plus plus team at NVIDIA does one every year,
我觉得这就有点像当年，是深蓝（Deep Blue）击败卡斯帕罗夫（Kasparov）的时候吗？然后人们就觉得，哦，不，计算机在国际象棋上更厉害了。但紧接着，他们就举办了一场比赛，允许人类在计算机的辅助下参赛。对，计算机辅助人类。那被认为是最佳组合。所以人机结合依然更胜一筹。对，计算机辅助人类。那被认为是最佳组合。所以人机结合依然更胜一筹。是的。所以，实际上在我们 GTC 的“与专家连线”环节中，通常我们在 GTC 上举办这些与专家连线的环节时，英伟达的 C++ 团队每年都会做一次，
we tend to get a bunch of questions that are not strictly on topic. And one of the ones we got yesterday was about, I thought it was going to be off topic first because it was about chat GPT, but it was actually very interesting. It was about like, hey, can you use chat GPT to auto-paralyze code? And usually if it's a question that I think is going to be off topic, I'm like a little reluctant to go and have us answer it live. But then I actually read it and I was like, ooh, this is actually, this opens up like an interesting topic of chat GPT-assisted or large language model-assisted programming, which is something I've been
我们往往会收到一堆并非严格切题的问题。我们昨天收到的其中一个问题，一开始我以为会是跑题的，因为它问的是 ChatGPT，但实际上非常有趣。它的内容是：“嘿，你们能用 ChatGPT 来自动并行化代码吗？”通常，如果遇到我觉得会跑题的问题，我会有那么一点不情愿让大家在线回答。但后来我仔细看了看，心想：噢，这其实挺有意思的，这开启了一个关于“ChatGPT 辅助编程”或“大语言模型辅助编程”的有趣话题。这也是我最近出于各种原因一直在深入思考的事情。
thinking about a lot recently for a variety of reasons. One, I am lazy. I really just do not want to spend hours and hours cranking out code myself. That just does not, it's not a good use of my time but two i have a bunch of uh uh ergonomic uh issues that that limit the number of hours i can i can actually code a bunch of like repetitive stress injury things from you got rsi you know when i was what you have rsi yeah yeah i didn't know that i mean it's pretty common um but uh you know. But that's one of the reasons why I don't do it. You consider APL less characters.
第一，我很懒。我真的不想花上几个小时亲自动手敲代码。那真的……那不是对我时间的有效利用。第二，我有一堆……呃……人体工学方面的问题，这限制了我每天实际能编码的小时数。比如有很多重复性劳损（RSI）的问题……你有 RSI，你知道的，当我……你也有 RSI？对，对。我以前不知道。我的意思是这挺常见的。但……你知道的。这也是我不想写代码的原因之一。你觉得 APL 的字符更少。
What? You consider APL less characters. Yeah. You know, the problem is, though, that you've got to type all those fancy characters. And you've got to use a bunch of key modifiers and layers to do that. And that's actually supposed to make it worse. But anyways, long story short is, I would like to write more code,
什么？你觉得 APL 的字符更少。对。你知道问题在于，你得输入所有那些花里胡哨的字符。你得使用一堆按键修饰符和组合层来做到这一点。而这实际上据说会让情况更糟糕。不过不管怎样，简而言之就是，
but I would not like to write more code, you know? I do know. So I was thinking the other day, until Elon perfects that little brain chip that we're all going to get implanted. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Pause, pause, pause. You're actually going to put something that that crazy dude creates in your head? Well, not the one that he makes, but see what I figure.
我想写更多的代码，但我又不想写更多的代码，你懂的？我懂的。所以我前几天就在想，除非埃隆（Elon）完美研制出我们都要植入大脑的那个小脑机芯片。哇，哇，哇，哇，哇。暂停，暂停，暂停。你真的要把那个疯狂的家伙造的东西塞进你的脑袋里吗？好吧，不是他造的那款，但我琢磨着……
He's really big on dogfooding, right? I was reading this article the other day about that that elon you know at tesla a lot of the testing got done by like the executives including elon like a lot of the testing for autopilot would be like elon would go and like drive his tesla with autopilot and then like he would send a bunch of bug reports and then then like that was their process like elon would go and drive the car and then like tell the engineers like go fix these things. Instead of, you know, having a more principled process. But, you know, I got a figure that Elon's going to be one of the first people to install this chip.
他非常笃信“自产自销”（dogfooding），对吧？我前几天读到过一篇文章，讲的是埃隆在特斯拉有很多测试都是由高管完成的，包括埃隆本人。比如自动驾驶的很多测试，都是埃隆亲自去开着装有自动驾驶的特斯拉，然后他会提交一堆 Bug 报告，接着……这就是他们的流程：埃隆去开车，然后告诉工程师们去修复这些问题。而不是采用一套更严谨的流程。不过，我琢磨着埃隆肯定会是第一批安装这个芯片的人之一。
And, you know, he's just going gonna be brain dead after that and so then and then once once elon is in a cyborg coma um you know maybe somebody sane and reasonable will uh will will take over the company and then they'll make like a safe uh brain chip and then i'll get that one um you know i'll get to generation two after the generation that elon and all the elon stands um install and uh turns them into zombies wait we were talking about rsi and coding less yeah yeah so my point my point was you know until that until i can get that that elon brain chip what that will allow me to just directly interface with the computer and just tell it like, you know, just directly output the code
然后，你知道的，他装完之后脑子就会彻底死机了。接着，一旦埃隆进入了赛博格昏迷状态，你知道的，也许某个神智清醒、讲道理的人就会接管公司，然后他们会造出一个安全的脑芯片，那到时候我再去装那个……你知道的，我会等到埃隆和所有埃隆的狂热粉丝们安装了第一代、变成僵尸之后，再去装第二代。等等，我们刚才不是在讨论 RSI 和减少写代码吗？对，对。所以我的观点是，直到……直到我能用上埃隆的那个脑芯片，那个能让我直接与计算机进行交互、把我想表达的代码直接从大脑输出到计算机里的芯片。在这之前，我一直在寻找其他能输出代码却又不用（你知道的）做任何工作的方法，因为我们已经确认过我很懒。显然，这些大语言模型，像 ChatGPT 和 GitHub Copilot，确实为此提供了机会。我一开始对 GitHub Copilot 持相当怀疑的态度，
from my mind to the computer. Until that happens, I've been searching for other ways that I can output code without, you know, doing any work because we've established I'm lazy. And obviously, these large language models, things like ChatGPT and GitHub Copilot, you know, offer opportunities for that. pretty skeptical of github co-pilot when it first came out um and i think that's just my the
而且我认为这只是我内心深处那个顽固的老头子在作祟，他对任何新事物都天生抱有怀疑态度。正如这个播客的听众可能知道的，我的开发设置并不是那种非常高级或现代化的。我就是打开一个 Shell，然后在 Vim 里搞定所有事情。对，几个星期前你乱入的那场直播里，有很多评论都在问：“为什么这家伙不把语法高亮打开？”
curmudgeon-y old man inside of me that is just inherently skeptical at any new thing like listeners this podcast probably know like i do not have a very uh advanced or modern uh development uh setup like i i i open up a shell and like i do all my stuff in v yeah there was on that sometimes on that live stream that you crashed a couple weeks ago there was a number of comments being like why does this guy not have syntax highlighting turned on yeah yeah and i don't believe in syntax highlighting. And, you know, it's just like for me, like I'm just happy with like just a Linux shell. And it's like, you know, half the time it's like I don't even want like some fancy builds. It's like I just want like ChatGPT are so promising and have such potential to transform how we operate that I'm actually interested in improving my development toolbox.
对，对，我不相信语法高亮。对我来说，我只要一个 Linux Shell 就很开心了。很多时候，甚至连那些花哨的构建工具我都不想要，我只是希望……但 ChatGPT 展现出的前景是如此广阔，具有如此巨大的潜力，能够改变我们的运作方式，以至于我其实很有兴趣改进一下我的开发工具箱。
And so I've been thinking a bit about what would I actually want? I think it's pretty clear that the correct interface for pair programming with an AI is not logging into chat GPT and asking it to do things and then copying, pasting output from it into another window and then trying it and then, you know, giving it
所以我一直在思考一个问题：我到底想要什么？很显然，与人工智能进行结对编程的正确界面，绝对不是登录 ChatGPT、让它做事、然后把它的输出复制粘贴到另一个窗口里、接着去测试它，再给它……
feedback. Like that's a lot of copying and pasting. I don't want to do that. I think I'd want something more like the GitHub Copilot, where it's integrated into your IDE, and as you start typing out stuff, it suggests auto-completions. So something that's built into your IDE and that can get feedback from can get feedback from your IDE was like the first thing I was thinking about. And then I was thinking a bit about the problem of, well, what if you've got like a really big code base? You know, like, like what if I, what if what I want to tell the AI to do is like, hey, AI, I have this 1 million line, like, internal proprietary code base that's not part of your training set. Like, and I want you to write me a PR for, that does this thing in this code base. And the problem there is that even GPT-4 has a fairly limited input size.
提供反馈。这中间有太多的复制粘贴了。我不想这么做。我想我要的应该更像是 GitHub Copilot 那样，它直接集成在你的 IDE 里，当你开始敲代码时，它会提供自动补全建议。所以，构建在 IDE 中并且能够从 IDE 获取反馈的东西，这是我最先想到的。然后我又思考了另一个问题：如果你有一个非常庞大的代码库怎么办？你知道的，如果我想让 AI 做的事情是：“嘿，AI，我这里有一个百万行级别的内部专有代码库，它不在你的训练集里。我希望你针对这个代码库给我写一个 Pull Request，去完成这个功能。”这里的问题在于，即使是 GPT-4，其输入规模也是相当有限的。
Like you could maybe feed in like, you know, let's say a hundred pages of text or something, but you probably couldn't feed in a million line code base, right? To it. And so asking it to do, to make some change across a large code base, not clear to me how exactly we'd go about doing that yet. But once I started thinking about that,
比如你大概只能喂给它一百页左右的文本，但你显然无法把一个百万行级别的代码库喂给它。所以要求它在一个庞大的代码库中进行某种更改，目前对我来说还不清楚具体该怎么做。不过一旦我开始思考这个问题，
it started occurring to me that, you know, what I really just want is I want to be able to go onto GitHub and file an issue against my project that describes the change that I want. And then the AI opens up a PR that, you know, implements that issue. And then I can give it feedback in the PR saying like, okay, well, this is broken here. And also importantly that because it's opening up a PR, it will get feedback from your CI results and whatnot,
我就渐渐意识到，我真正想要的是：我希望能够直接去 GitHub 上针对我的项目提交一个 Issue，在里面描述我想要的更改。然后 AI 就会自动开启一个 Pull Request 来实现这个 Issue。接着我可以在 PR 里给它反馈，说：“好吧，这里有点问题。”更重要的是，由于它开启的是 Pull Request，它就能从你的 CI 测试结果等内容中获得反馈，
so then it can go in. You don't even have to tell it, hey, this code that you wrote for me, it doesn't actually compile because it'll figure it out on its own when it sends the PR in. So that's more or less the interface that I settled up on wanting. Then it doesn't matter what ID. You don't need to use a particular ide or anything it's just you just i just type up a high level description of what i want in an issue and then the ai goes out and does it so uh somebody at microsoft or github or open ai you know get on that get on that, get on that. I mean, I feel like it's incredibly doable for a certain category of issue.
这样它就可以自己去调整。你甚至都不用去告诉它：“嘿，你给我写的这段代码其实编译不过去。”因为它把 PR 提交上去后，自己就能发现并搞定。所以这差不多就是我最终设定的理想交互界面。这样一来，用什么 IDE 都无所谓了。你不需要使用特定的 IDE 或其他东西，只需要在 Issue 里用高层级的语言描述我想要什么，然后 AI 就会出去把事情办妥。所以，微软、GitHub 或 OpenAI 的哪位朋友，快去把这个实现了吧！快去搞定它，搞定它。我觉得对于某类特定类别的 Issue 来说，这绝对是极其可行的。
Like the kind of thing, like imagine adding W error, like W all to your CMake file. And then like you have a bunch of errors. And so you just post the output of like, you know, add this command to CMake and then go fix all this stuff. I feel like that's super doable.
比如那种……想象一下，在你的 CMake 文件里加上 `-Werror` 和 `-Wall`，然后你就会遇到一堆错误。接着你只要把输出结果贴进去，说“把这个命令加到 CMake 里，然后去修复所有这些问题”。我觉得这超级可行。
But there's like a larger category of things that is going to be – I'm not saying it's not possible, but I think it's going to be a long time before, you know. Well, I mean, obviously, we're going to have a future episode of this podcast where we live code with ChatGPT. But I think the potentially one route to get to what I want is that I suspect we're going to see large companies in the future start building models that are trained on their internal code bases. Oh, yeah, for sure. There's already a couple startups that are specifically, whether it's code bases, I know that there's one that's like SharePoint trained or something. I like literally, I'm, I'm pretty sure I'll find it and put it in the show notes. There was an episode of the NVIDIA AI podcast, which is hosted by Noah Kravitz. I might've made,
但还有更大范围的一类事情——我不是说它不可能实现，但我认为还需要很长一段时间，你知道的。好吧，显然我们以后会有一期播客是关于用 ChatGPT 进行现场编码的。但我认为实现我想要的目标的潜在途径之一是，我猜未来我们会看到大公司开始构建针对其内部代码库进行训练的模型。噢，对，肯定的。已经有几家初创公司专门做这个了，不管是针对代码库——我知道有一家是针对 SharePoint 训练的什么的。我敢打赌，我一定能找到它并把它放在Shownotes里。那是英伟达 AI 播客的一期节目，由诺亚·克拉维茨（Noah Kravitz）主持。我可能把他的姓记错了，
I may have made that last name up. Um, But I think like two episodes ago or three episodes ago, they had an episode on this startup that's doing exactly that, like internally trained LLMs that have the goal of providing a search engine that's trained on a cornucopia of proprietary internal stuff. But yeah, I, I actually, I'm pretty interested in, in seeing where, where this, where this space goes of AI assisted development. I think it's, I think it's very promising. Yeah. I mean, I've already seen some cool things with it,
但我记得大概在两期或三期节目之前，他们采访了一家专门做这种事的初创公司：训练内部大语言模型，其目标是提供一个基于海量专有内部资料进行训练的搜索引擎。不过，是的，我其实非常期待看到这个 AI 辅助开发的领域未来会走向何方。我觉得它极具前景。对，我的意思是，我已经从其中看到了一些很酷的东西，
but the cool things that I've seen, they've been impressive in the results they've produced, but not in the interface that one has to them. And a lot of them have been things like, have chat GPT write a chrome extension form for you that does something and and that's pretty easy because writing a chrome consent like you don't need any knowledge of a particular code base for that it's just a knowledge of a very well known publicly documented series of apis it's a little bit harder if if you if you want it to be like hey like i have this existing
但我看到的那些很酷的东西，它们产生的结果虽然令人印象深刻，但它们的交互界面却并非如此。其中很多都像是：让 ChatGPT 帮你写一个执行某种功能的 Chrome 扩展程序。这相对容易，因为编写一个 Chrome 扩展程序并不需要你对某个特定的代码库有任何了解，它只需要你了解一套广为人知的、公开记录的 API。如果你希望它说：“嘿，我这里有一个现有的代码库，我希望你帮我在上面进行迭代开发”，或者甚至只是“嘿，我想要从零开始启动一个新的代码库，你来帮我构建”，这就稍微困难一些了。对，就像我们请肖恩·巴克斯特（Sean Baxter）来做客时聊的那样，那才真是改变游戏规则的事情。我有三个不同的 C++ 20/23 个人项目代码库，甚至还有一个是工作用的，在每一个代码库的待办事项（To-Do）清单里，都有一项是“添加 Clang-Tidy”，因为这并不是一件轻而易举的事，尤其是当你里面既有 CUDA 代码、又不仅仅只有 C++ 代码的时候。如果我能去问某个……我觉得我以前在这个播客里聊过这个，它叫 GPT-Duck 或者叫 Duck-GPT，也就是集成在 GitHub 里的 ChatGPT。
code base and i want you to help me like like iterate on it or even just if it's like hey i want to like start a new code base from scratch that you were you were going to help me build yeah well that's when we had sean baxter on that was the thing that i think is just like a game changer like i have three different c++ 20 23 personal project repos or even one of them's for work and like a to-do item on every single one of those is to add clang tidy because it's just a non-trivial thing especially if you have cuda code and not just c++ code and if i could just ask some like i think that i've talked about this on this podcast before is that it's called gpt duck or duck gpt which is like g like GitHub integrated with chat GPT.
如果我能直接把它指向一个代码库，然后说：“请帮我配置好 Clang-Tidy，采用基础的 Google 标准，并修改 CMake 文件，让它能自动应用到所有的头文件以及这些 C++ 和 CUDA 文件上”，然后它就自己去把这事儿办了。那简直绝了。又或者，我上周花了大约六个小时试图在 CMake 里配置一个特定的东西，我当时希望它能生成一堆目标文件（object files），并带上能够捕获编译器中优化备注（optimization remarks）的编译标志。
And if I can just point it at a repo and say, please go set up clang tidy with like the baseline Google standards and modify the CMake file so that it automatically works on like all headers and these C++ and CUDA files. And it just went and did that. That would be phenomenal. Or like I like spent like six hours trying to set up like a particular thing in CMake last week where I was like I wanted it to like build a bunch of object files with flags that would capture optimization remarks in the compilers.
如果当时有 ChatGPT 的话，它肯定能很快弄清楚怎么做。这就是关键所在——这些任务，我甚至都不想称之为“管道工作”（plumbing work），因为我觉得这好像贬低了一大类人的工作——但我们毕竟不是构建工程师（build engineers），或者至少对我自己而言，我绝不认为自己是一个构建工程师。好吧，我的意思是，我花在构建系统相关事情上的时间比例……但这就是重点啊！想象一下，如果你只要说出一个问题，并告诉它“这就是我想要的”……对，这就是那种……
And it would have been so like I'm sure that chat gpt could have figured out how to do that real quick and that's the thing is these are the kind of tasks that it's literally like i don't want to say plumbing work because i feel like that's like denigrating like a whole you know category of folks's jobs but like we are not build engineers or like i do at least for myself i do not consider myself a build engineer in the slightest well i mean i feel like the percentage of time that i end up spending doing build thing build system related things i mean that's the whole point though is like imagine if you could just say say a question and say this is what i want yeah and that's the you know the i think the more um soft like creative software engineering stuff is like algorithm design or work on thruster cub
我觉得更偏向软件工程中“创造性”的部分是算法设计，或者是从事推进工作（trusters）什么的，或者你在做的任何事情，而不是那些用来设置单元测试、或者让 CI 流程在各种配置矩阵上运行的管道或基础设施工作。那些东西……你知道的，并不是我期待去做的事情。如果我能把这些破事儿彻底自动化……在 Oxide and Friends 播客里，他们也有一期节目聊到过：想象一下，这甚至都不像是在想“哦，我们是在取代某人的工作”，而是去想想那些缺乏真正文档的 API 或代码库，你只要把 ChatGPT 往上一放，说：“嘿，给我生成一份类似 Read the Docs 风格的、Doxygen 生成的文档”，然后它就直接完成了……你知道的，这会有多棒！而且它做出来的效果会比……
or whatever it is you're doing it's not the the plumbing work or the infrastructure work to set up some unit test or get some ci process working on you know a matrix of configurations that stuff is like you know it's not the stuff that i look forward to doing and if i could if i could automate the hell out of that stuff it's on oxide and friends they had an episode too where they were talking about like imagine it's not even like you think oh we're replacing someone's job or whatever it's like think about the apis or code bases that don't really have doc documentation and you just like put chat gpt on it and said hey give me a like a read the doc style uh doxygen generated thing and it just went and did it like you know how how awesome that would be and like it would do more than just like generating
你可以对它说：“尽你最大努力，根据你对函数语义的评估，用英文记录下这些 API 分别在做什么。”这太惊人了！想象一下这会有多神奇！它做出来的效果可能比一个对代码库一无所知、正试图手工去写的普通人类还要好。就像你雇了一个实习生来做这事一样。太令人兴奋了。我觉得是的，确实如此。
like you could say and do your best to in english document what what each of these apis are doing based on you know your assessment of the semantics of the function like amazing imagine how amazing that would be like it would probably do better than what a human would do that didn't know anything about the code base and that was trying to do it by hand. Like if you got a co-op to do it or something like that. Yeah. It's exciting. I think it is, yeah.
好了，那我们来聊聊我的话题吧。等等。我们已经聊到 22 分钟了。那我们再聊几个随性的杂项吧。这将是第 122 期，接下来是第 123 期。事实上，在跳进第 123 期之前，先给听众们一点小福利、一点小剧透，说说我们接下来要聊什么。噢，我们要聊的是 C++ Ranges（范围）以及如何对它们进行向量化。但更广泛地说，我们将讨论
All right. So let's talk about my thing. Wait. We're at the 22-minute mark. Let's talk about a couple of random more things. This will be episode 122 and then episode 123. Actually, give the listener a little taste, a little preview before we jump into episode 123 of what we're going to be talking about. Oh, we are going to be talking about C++ ranges and how to vectorize them. But more generally, we're going to be talking about
在这些类似数组语言范式的循环中，如何为了组合不同的算法原语来进行循环优化。所以，是的，我就说这些。句号。好了，听众们必须等上一周才能听到那个话题了。这就是节目的运作方式。我想在最后的这几分钟里，你提到了与英伟达库开发人员的“与专家连线”活动。这实际上是在暗指目前正在进行的 GTC 2023 虚拟大会。
optimizing loops in these sort of array language type paradigms for composing different algorithmic primitives. So, yeah, I'm going to go with that. Full stop. All right. Well, the listener has to wait a week in order to hear that topic. That's the way things work. I guess in the last few minutes here, I mean, you referenced a connect with experts with some of the library folks at NVIDIA. That is implicitly a reference to the GTC 2023 virtual conference that's happening right now.
顺便跟感兴趣的朋友提一下。大会是从周一开幕的。大家听到这期节目的时候可能正值周五或是周末。所以到那个时候它已经闭幕了，但所有的演讲都可以在网上免费观看。我会写一份行程报告，重点介绍我最喜欢的一些演讲。我的意思是，我目前只看了四个。你今天早上看主题演讲了吗？没有，它和 C++ 库演进小组电话会议撞时间了。
Just in case folks are interested. It started on Monday. People are probably listening to this on Friday or on the weekend. So it is wrapped at this point, but all the talks will be online for free. And I'll have a trip report highlighting some of my favorites. I mean, I've only watched four so far. Did you watch the keynote this morning? No, it was at the same time as the C++ Library Evolution Telecom.
但我其实没法真正参与那个会议，因为我不得不通过联邦快递（FedEx）隔夜加急把东西寄到她的酒店。酒店拒绝签收。然后联邦快递的人就把包裹给退回来了。这真是一场折腾。接着另外两三件别的事情也同时炸雷了。不过大家都平安无事吧？就像那种不是悲剧的紧急情况……没有，没有，都不是什么紧急情况，全都是些狗血抓马事件。好吧，好吧，那还在持续中。我的意思是，现在已经结束了。不过如果大家想去看看有什么内容的话……呃，我不知道你有没有看
But I couldn't actually really participate in that because I had to overnight FedEx to her hotel. The hotel refused to sign for them. And so then the FedEx people didn't – took the package back. And it was a whole ordeal. And then two or three other things concurrently blew up. Everybody's okay, though? like emergencies that is not like tragic or like no no none of them were emergencies all of them were drama okay all right that's ongoing i mean it's over at this point but if folks want to check things out anything uh i'm not sure if you've taken a
日程表，我知道你有一场关于 C++ 标准并行性的演讲。这跟你去年讲的是同一场吗？是更新过的内容，还是……我是不是得把这段剪掉？不，你知道的，我可以对听众坦诚相告，这是一场更新过的演讲。我原本希望我们能做一个全新的、专门针对 Senders 的演讲，但我们最后还是做成了一场更新版的演讲。好的，你有没有看过或者还没看哪些演讲？我猜你大概没时间看任何演讲，但你已经看过日程表了吗？还是说你没时间？我的同事亚历克斯（Alex）将发表一场关于量子计算内容的精彩演讲，也就是他们正在从事的量子 C++ 相关的东西。
look at the schedule i know you've got a c++ standard parallelism talk is this the same talk you gave last year is it a updated or um or do i have to cut this out no you know i i can be honest with the listener it is an updated talk i had hoped that we were going to make a a whole new uh talk specifically on senders but we just ended up uh making an updated talk okay any any talks that you've seen or not seen? I guess probably you haven't had time to watch any, but have you checked out the schedule yet? Or no, you haven't had time? My colleague Alex is going to give a cool talk about the quantum computing stuff, the quantum C++ stuff that they're working on.
所以那可能会非常有趣。除此之外，没了，我什么都没看。好吧，我会在那场演讲的描述里放一个链接。另外，明天在 GTC 第三天的主日程之外，还有半天的 Apple Seeds 2023 大会，这是一场面向对 APL 感兴趣的人的、类似初学者在线免费虚拟会议。所以我打算去……而且那其实是……
So that's probably going to be pretty interesting. Other than that, no, I got nothing. All right. I'll put a link in the description of that talk. Also in the past, tomorrow on top of GTC Day 3 is the half-day Apple Seeds 2023 conference, which is a sort of beginner online free virtual conference for people that are interested in APL. So I'm going to be... And that's actually...
你知道最好的……这里有个问题。这里有个冷知识问题，布莱斯。虚拟会议最好的地方是什么？其实也没多少好地方。我的意思是，它让内容更容易获取了。但有一点……我可以穿着睡衣在卫生间里做演示。
You know what the best... Here's a question. Here's a trivia question, Bryce. What's the best thing about virtual conferences? There's not a ton of nice things. I mean, it's more accessible stuff. But there is one thing that... I get to wear my pajamas in my bathroom while presenting.
你平时大概也能这么干，而且以前可能也干过。但别给我出主意，不是这个。虚拟会议比线下会议好得多的地方在于，真正好得多、好得多的地方是——如果你参加的是那种在 Zoom 上做演讲的虚拟会议，就像明天的 Apple Seeds 那样，把那部分剪掉，然后去做你本来应该做的事情：要么在 YouTube 上直播，要么在某个支持倍速播放的视频服务上直播。因为我其实从来不看任何直播演讲，我实在没有耐性，特别是当我坐在椅子上时，以 1.0 倍速看东西。所以通常我只会看前一个时段的演讲，并且会用
You still probably could do that and probably have in the past but no no but don't give me any ideas that's not it there's something that's way better about virtual conferences than that that is way better way better about virtual conferences compared to in person it is that and if you're a virtual conference that does your talks on zoom like apple seeds will be tomorrow cut that out and do what you should be doing which is having them either streamed on youtube or streamed on some video service that can be sped up because i actually don't really watch any talks live because i don't really have the patience especially when i'm sitting in my chair to watch things at one time speed. So usually I'll just watch talks from the slot before and I'll watch
2 倍速观看。这其实是现在……你居然用 2 倍速看我的演讲。我说话本来就挺快的。不。我的意思是，是的，我看所有的演讲都这样。我唯一听播客会用 2.3 倍速，我看所有演讲都用 2.5 倍速。我唯一会放慢语速的情况……你脑子绝对有点毛病。我的意思是，你这人……你就像个那种……你总是干一些非常像学者（savant）一样的事情。说实话，我觉得这倒不像是学者，这有点像那种……你知道“多少根头发才能算胡子”的悖论吗？如果 500 根头发是胡子，那显然 499 根也必须是胡子，498 根也是。然后它递归一直递减到零。
them at 2x. That's actually one of the hardest things now about... You watch my talks at 2x speed. I talk pretty fast. No. I mean, yes, I watch all talks. The only time I listen to podcasts at 2.3 times speed and i listen to all talks at 2.5 speed the only time i slow there's something wrong with you i mean you're you know you're you're like really you you you do all these things that are very savant like i mean it's not it's not honestly i don't think it's savant like it's kind of like the you know how many hairs makes a beard if 500 hairs is a beard then clearly 499 must be in 498. And then it's recursively goes down to zero.
一旦你……你其实很难分辨 1.0 倍速和 1.1 倍速的区别。于是你把它调到 1.1 倍速，接着你对 1.1 到 1.2 倍速也如法炮制。然后你根本不会察觉，不知不觉中，你就已经开到 2.3 倍速了。然后你每隔一段时间回头……我听我的波兰语播客是用 1.0 倍速的。有时候当我切到下一个播客时，我会听到它以 1.0 倍速播放，那种感觉……听到这些人说话这么慢，会让我感到焦虑。这大概对我的演讲技巧也没什么帮助，因为我以前在演讲时语速就很快。但现在我觉得，正是因为我听这些东西的速度太快了……不过重点是，我唯一会放慢语速的情况是在某些播客里。第一，如果那是某种我不会说的外语；第二，如果音频质量很差，或者有什么特别的动作。你现在甚至还在听其他外语播客？对啊。你能给那些摸鱼的人留点活路吗？兄弟，我不知道……我不知道那些人……每个人……我觉得我搞定……你可不是什么摸鱼的人，老兄，恕我直言。我绝对是个摸鱼的人。我是摸鱼的教科书级代表。好吧，MR……
As soon as like you can't, you can't really tell the difference between 1.0 times speed and 1.1 times speed. And then so you move it up to 1.1 and then you do the same thing with 1.1 to 1.2. And then you just don't really notice until before you know it, you're at 2.3 times speed. And then you go back every once in a while. I listen to my Polish podcast at 1.0 times speed. And then sometimes when I skip to the next podcast, I'll hear it at 1.0 times speed. And like, it gives me anxiety to hear these people talking so slowly. It probably also doesn't help with my own presentation skills because I already was
EWG 的前负责人……你知道的，某个名人曾经说过——我不知道是谁，我也不在乎——懒人就是聪明人，因为他们总能找到最高效的方式来做事情。不，呃，他们原话是……我觉得大概意思是：
a fast talker in my presentations. But now I think because I listen to these things so quickly. But the point is, is the only times I slow things down are in certain podcasts. One, if it's in a different language that I don't speak or two, if the audio quality is bad or if there is an act. You're listening to other podcast to podcast in other languages now yeah i mean can you can you leave some room for for the for the the slackers man who i don't know i don't know any of those everyone i i think i got her you're not a slacker my guy i hate to break it to you i am definitely a slacker i am the book definition of a slacker okay mr
聪明人思考，其他人干活。我根本没打算干活。我只是个负责出点子的人。不过我不同意。我最喜欢的名言之一，
mr head of ewg and uh you know a famous person once said and i i don't know who and i don't care a lazy person is a smart person because they're always finding the most efficient way to do things um no uh what they said was um i think it was something along the lines of, smart people think, other people work. I got no intention of doing work. I'm just the ideas guy. I mean, I disagree. A couple of my favorite quotes,
我最喜欢的名言之一是托马斯·爱迪生（Thomas Edison）说的：“天才是百分之一的灵感，加百分之九十九的汗水。”我非常喜欢这句名言。你和我对生活的哲学截然不同。我喜欢的另一句名言是什么来着？我一时想不起来了，但……对，我只是……每个人都有不同的风格，对吧？而我的风格是，我想要消费简直荒谬的大量信息。这就是阅读书籍的问题所在，
one of my favorite quotes is by Thomas Edison. Genius is 1% inspiration and 99% perspiration. I love that quote. You and I have different philosophies to life. What's another one of my favorite quotes that's in that? It's escaping me right now but uh yeah i just i have uh everyone has like a different style right and my my style is that i want to consume just like an absurdly large amount of information like that's the kind of the problem with reading books
你知道的，大多数书里大概有 95% 都是在浪费时间。所以你以后也会去买那个埃隆的芯片喽？哦，只要他们一推出某种通过审批的智能增强设备，绝对的。我觉得现在的手机……我觉得我们已经是经过智能增强的人类了。有多少人能正常地——打个引号——在没有手机的情况下生活？我们花在通过这个每个人随身携带的设备与人沟通的时间，比我们面对面交流的时间要多得多。而且有太多事情了，你知道的，比如人们在字典里查单词，从 A 点导航到 B 点。这一切都和我们小时候完全不同了。
you know most books are like 95 kind of like a waste of time so then you're gonna get the elon chip too oh as soon as they have some kind of intelligence augmentation thing that is like approved absolutely like i think this phone right now like i think we're already like intelligence augmented human beings like how many people can operate normally quote unquote, without a cell phone? Like that's how we spend more time communicating with people through this device that everyone always has on them than we do like face to face. And like there's so many things, you know, like people looking up words in a dictionary, finding directions from point A to point B. It's all completely changed from when we were kids.
是的，我认为我们已经是经过智能增强的人类了，而下一步就是一个芯片。我觉得自己出门还得随身带一堆东西，这简直太荒谬了。当我跑步时，我耳朵里塞着硬件耳机，口袋里装着信用卡和可能还有一张身份证，带着一部用来听歌的手机，然后还要戴一块 GPS 手表——虽然技术上讲我可以用手表来听歌，但我喜欢折腾我的播客。所以这就变成了一部手机、一副耳机、一块手表和信用卡。所有这些东西都可以变成我额头上的几个贴纸和手腕里的一个芯片。走吧。得了吧。我太累了。我们到 60 岁的时候，回想起以前出门必须带上所有这些东西——耳机和各种杂七杂八的日子……
And yeah, I think we are already like intelligence augmented human beings and the next step is some chip. Like I think it's absurd that I have to carry around a Jeep. When I go running, I have headphones in my ears that are hardware, a credit card and maybe an ID in my pocket, a cell phone for music, and then a GPS watch, which technically I could use for my music, but I like, you know, messing around with my podcast. So it's like a phone, headphones, a watch, and credit cards. All of that stuff could be like a couple stickers on my forehead and a chip in my wrist. Like, let's go. Come on. I'm so tired. Like we're going to, by the time we're 60, we're going to look back at the days when you would leave the house and you'd have to bring all this stuff, these headphones and all this stuff.
然后就会觉得，这些东西以后都会植入我们体内，或者变成贴纸贴在我们的额头上。那简直太棒了。我简直迫不及待了。事实上，我居然还得掏出一张带有 RFID 功能的塑料卡片来付钱……你得把这期节目的标题取名为《额头上的贴纸》。那难道不酷吗？老实说，干脆把耳机直接塞进我的耳膜里算了，反正我大概已经在不知不觉中通过开太大声听音乐慢慢损害自己的听力了。
And it's just going to be like, it's going to be in us or stickers on our foreheads. And that is the best. And I can't wait for that. The fact that I'm pulling out a piece of plastic that has some RFID thing so I can pay for stuff. You're going to have to title this episode stickers on our foreheads. Wouldn't that be amazing? And honestly, just put the headphones in my eardrums because I'm probably already slowly destroying my hearing by listening to music too loud.
我要去树林里买间小木屋，再买支枪来把所有的机器人全崩了。不，你才不会。你会舒舒服服地坐在云端，高高在上。总之，我们已经超过 30 分钟了。我们绝对已经超过 30 分钟了。第 122 期节目到此结束。请务必查看您的播客应用或 ADSPthepodcast.com 获取相关链接。
I'm buying a cabin in the woods and a gun to shoot all the robots. No, you're not. You're going to be right there sitting up in the clouds, above the clouds. Anyways, we're past the 30-minute mark. We're definitely past the 30-minute mark. End episode 122. Be sure to check your podcast app or ADSPthepodcast.com for links to any
我要在树林里买间小屋，再买把枪来射击所有的机器人。不，你不会的。你将会坐在云端，云层之上。无论如何，我们已经超过了30分钟的大关。我们绝对超过了30分钟的大关。结束第122集。请务必查看你的播客应用程序或ADSPthepodcast.com以获取相关链接
of the topics that we discussed today and a link to a GitHub discussion where you can ask any questions or leave any comments that you have. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们今天讨论的话题以及一个GitHub讨论链接，您可以在那里提出任何问题或留下您的意见。感谢收听。希望您喜欢并度过美好的一天。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。